hello and welcome to this video let's
get started
novelty yeah probably not but 96 is an
ordinarily huh there's nothing new Under
the Sun
you
don't think that this can be bad
you
so they don't just develop
yes try to secure c5 him for the noid
gal do we go efore here for a center or
a couple of things here that make some
sense relief
and also
a bishop is three this kind of thing
Queen d2 Bishop h6
hmm yeah some opportunities not just one
way to play
efore looked a bit more more standard
maybe he's playing c6 now no we five
interesting
[Music]
um so I can shake I think I should take
you
you
you
I know I've spotted if he takes with the
Bishop b3
hey it doesn't have anything good on the
longer okay this one
hmmm it's not exactly a move that I
expected
you
it's very weakening but okay it's
probably not not terrible should age six
looks like something that I want to play
you
Nanaji for I played Bishop Oh Kim
yeah now it's it's tough to resist
Safari
for he had d5 against the smooth which
now seems impossible as e5 is hanging
take on c5 and other than that the whole
structure is a complete mess
I don't really see a good move now for
black
does he have any reason some unexpected
technical resource on I don't see it
really
okay now I can take a d6
and Rudy one I guess 94 is also strong a
routine one is a good move for the tech
36 bond
huh maybe h3 was an idea as well
you
no one threatening to take on f6
if he takes with the peace island in the
night 8/3 Winston right if he takes with
the night a ticket five so what exactly
is black smoke
yeah but if I play
I mean h3 is totally enough
[Music]
so night takes or queen takes
it doesn't matter
you
excellent
so Queen takes d6 know
you
now this is a bit of a disaster Black
has so many weaknesses
and it started early on with a five and
taking with the F pawn on e6
ah
now they did that whole opening went
downhill pretty off pretty quickly 96's
order never saw that one very early 96
this is of course well known with D 64
inserted but it's very early
six now a five there are now many many
setups this is maybe not the best move
is interesting though okay you went in
five which I took and now this is the
normal move and should be played
developes don't weaken your structure
attack upon looks very normal
they would have done that and now you
can't even think of getting this back
into the game and now this this doesn't
feel right relieve Queen d2 this is one
idea
in d5 weakens even more I mean he know
he has many weaknesses nc5 I think looks
very normal
he's got a four oh shoot
that's a big mystery
I did not see that that enables him to
play d5 next
that means c5 wasn't a good idea you
have to play d1 first and then think
about this okay yes the way this turned
out was was great for me would be one
you know how does he keep all those
covered I don't don't seem and the
engine is already pretty harsh there I'm
just winning everything here yeah I
wrote the eight helps but it's falling
apart
okay guys thanks for watching